everyone was so drunk but no one even
remembers what you said I remember I
blogged the whole thing
www.crete thoughts.gov dot
www.backslash Creed thoughts check it
out
last year Creed asked me how to set up a
Blog
wanting to protect the world from being
exposed to Creed's brain I open up a
Word document on his computer and put an
address at the top
I've read some of it
even for the Internet it's
pretty shocking
strike scream and run
all right let's try it
may have been my fault what the hell
four seconds come on three two one stop
you're eating and the winner is Andy
Bernard with 14 hot dogs
one came up 13 hot dogs everybody
oh nobody told me we're gonna have hot
dogs
Dwight you didn't hear decapitated whole
big thing we had a funeral for a bird
pretty sure none of that's real
you're not real man
okay Ryan you told Toby that Creed has a
distinct old man smell
I know exactly what he's talking about I
sprout mung beans on a damp paper towel
in my desk drawer very nutritious but
they smell like death how's everyone
doing my door is always open if anyone
wants to talk I don't want to talk I
want my laptop back nobody's deals from
Crete Brad and gets away with it
the last person to do this disappeared
his name
Creed Bratton
buttons
[Applause]
in the parking lot today there was a
circus copier did tricks on the high
wire a lady tried to give away a baby
that looked like a cat there was a
Dwight impersonator and a gym
impersonator a strong man crushed a
turtle I laughed and I cried
not bad for a day in the life of a dog
food company
I didn't realize that everybody here
dresses up every year me neither
it's Halloween
that is really really good timing
hi we received the call
I don't know anything about that we were
tipped off about a possible narcotic
situation here Pam hey I got this okay
hello officers Dwight Schrute former
volunteer sheriff's deputy listen I may
have inside information that someone is
hiding drugs in this very office
just pretend like we're talking until
the cops leave
hey cream hey you sound great you guys
up to uh
you're the man buddy
I run a small fake ID company for my car
with a laminating machine that I swipe
from the share station
fun stuff
where's the website go as fast as
possible we want to start retraining
people ASAP so we can hit the ground
running with the new system cool beans
we're screwed otherwise us you and me
the old timers I am not old you are old
you are like a hundred you're over 40
That's the cutoff are you listening to
what he's saying retraining new system
youth I'm telling you this kid is the
Grim Reaper you deal with this or you me
Sammy Phyllis the chicken with a car
we're goners
all right
Creed yes sir
everything okay everything's cool dude
I'm 30.
well in November I'll be 30. hey good
morning you tell Stanley that I have
asthma because I don't if it gets out
they won't let me scuba if I can't Scuba
then what's this all been about what am
I working toward I don't want to blow
this this is what all good Law
Enforcement Officers dream of
chance to solve an actual crime
that is Northern Lights cannabis indica
it's marijuana
Thunderman this is Pam
hey go ahead
a lot of jazz cats are blind
but they can play the piano like
nobody's business
I'd like to put the piano in front of
Pam without her glasses and see what
happens
I'd also like to see your topless
it's yours I want to do a cartwheel but
real casual like none of them make a big
deal out of it but I know everybody saw
it there's one stunning gorgeous
cartwheel how's it going I'm having a
little trouble motivating look at where
you're going to be doing the cartwheel
so look where you're going to be placing
your hand so pick a spot
you ready to do this yes sir you know
what I'm going to stay here as long as
it takes I really appreciate it
go
I get it
you did the perfect cartwheel
okay good in a rush that's all I had to
do all year congratulations
all right well all right see you
tomorrow where's your place
oh it's on uh Linden Ave or the Quarry
oh cool beans man I live by the Quarry
we should hang out by the Quarry and
throw things down there
definitely we should
[Music]
oh
it's a real shame about it huh yeah must
really have you thinking it's about what
the older you get the bigger the chance
is you're gonna die
you knew that Ed was decapitated
it's drunk as a skunk he was flying down
Route Six he slides under an 18-wheeler
pop it snaps right off
that is the way to go instant death very
smart you know a human can go on living
for several hours after being
decapitated
you're thinking of a chicken
what did I say
Hey cuz
you're having money problems no you
didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away Creed Braden has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed Bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Schneider how would that help
Creed in Monopoly you go bankrupt you
lose you don't go by Monopoly man that
game is nuts nobody just picks up get
out of jail free cards those things cost
thousands
is a good point bankruptcy Michael is
Nature's do-over it's a fresh start it's
a clean slate or the witness protection
program not at all
I want to work with Jimmy Carter and
help build gnomes twice what about you I
will not be participating as there is no
evidence that charity Works uh
correction I give to a foundation that
teaches homeless children nautical Flags
signaling
changes lives thank you Andy I'm not
doing it for you I'm doing it for the
preservation of nautical flag signaling
Dwight you will be participating no
thank you participation is mandatory
Dwight but you can choose whatever cause
you like
fine I choose the global relief
Foundation great which was recently
discovered to be a front for the Taliban
oh for goodness yeah the Taliban in
Afghanistan the Taliban is the worst
great heroine though
this is so great huh
we should do this much more often I
think we hang out in appropriate amount
of time
doing in here this is the woman's roof
hearing here I pay for that privilege
I'm a pretty normal guy I do one weird
thing I like to go in the women's room
for number two I've been caught several
times and I have paid dearly
foreign